hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you I'm just
checking in to see how your weeks going
hot [ __ ] you're doing and everything and
your [ __ ] laughs all right let's get
into it I already recorded this podcast
I recorded it from my movie trailer
yesterday but for some reason the file
corrupted so now I have to do it again
which is alright because I would have
made a fool of myself because I thought
last night was Game three of the NBA
Finals and Game five of the Stanley Cup
final I'm like why can't those two
leagues get on the same [ __ ] page and
kind of you know just pick different
nights but evidently that's already
happened so I apologized to the NBA and
the NFL for the podcast that they never
heard I actually watched Gabe [ __ ]
three last night of Toronto verse Golden
State Warriors and yeah it was great
game it was just you know just watching
Toronto no matter how much Golden State
kept coming back they just kept they
couldn't cut it less than [ __ ] at ten or
nine they stayed out in front of him
they hit some big shots they blocked a
bunch of shots and all of that [ __ ] you
know this is uh and it was very easy to
root for Toronto you know it was very
easy to root for because they weren't
cutting to drink every five [ __ ]
seconds whatever the hell they're doing
like I tune I'm tuning in to watch the
Raptors first the Warriors
I'm not tuning in to watch Drake watch
the Raptors and the Warriors I don't
understand it alright but I've already
covered that
so anyway congratulations to them I
didn't see clay play my I don't know I
don't know [ __ ] about basketball but it
seemed like he wasn't playing that much
either but um we'll see well we will see
what happens
you know what is [ __ ] you know what's
getting like [ __ ] becoming a trope
though is them cutting to Toronto sports
fans standing outside their [ __ ]
arena and you know every time I see that
I'm just like I don't want to watch
these people [ __ ] hang their heads in
misery of another goddamn loss it would
be I'm still rooting for Toronto despite
all that other BS that's going on out
there so congratulations to them you
have two victories away from your first
bucket championship at least in
basketball in hockey since I've been
alive I don't know what's been going on
with your well you got the Toronto was
it the Argonauts the Rough Riders the
Stampede the Eagles the muroids I don't
know I don't know anything about the CFL
the Eskimos alright let's let's talk
about what I really want to talk about
let's talk a bottle Saint Louis Blues
coming back in Game four and quite
frankly kicking the [ __ ] out of my
Boston Bruins I've never seen a Bruins
team get manhandled like this in my 40
years of watching them and we are simply
not built for the kind of hockey that
st. Louis is playing and neither was st.
Louis I'm sorry neither was San Jose and
the result of that was their top three
players were unable to finish the series
and I don't know this is gonna be where
I this is this is what I believe okay
this is somebody who never got beyond
[ __ ] Pond Hockey you know in that
sport even then I I wasn't even good on
the pond cross over one side couldn't
could stop on one side couldn't skate
backwards the way st. Louis is playing
the Bruins need to wrap it up by Game
six or I don't see us winning it because
I don't think we're gonna have enough
good players left because they're just
taking runs at everybody and they're
running our goalie and they're playing a
trap defense so the way to beat those
guys
is you have to get up you got a score
first which will hopefully make them
take more chances so they're not just
gonna play that [ __ ] stupid trap
defense we got a dump and chase you know
so they can protect their [ __ ]
astoundingly mediocre goaltender but I
will say this I've been a fan of not
only sports but sports history and this
is my prediction if st. Louis wins the
Cup which they could very well do which
I felt from the beginning which is why I
never understood people don't deal we're
gonna [ __ ] sweep these guys it's like
they are big and that fast I didn't
realize how filthy they were though
which is fine though because it's
[ __ ] playoff hockey and this has
always happened but the problem is is
that because of all the whiny snowflake
[ __ ] out there who kept pressuring them
to get fighting out of the game what I'm
actually watching is a different kind of
gunnery it's funny that the goons used
used to [ __ ] police I don't know and
I just think the direction that this
game went we got rid of too many Shaun
Thornton's
and too many [ __ ] Adam McQuaid's
because those are the guys that were
missing right now when we would easily
easily be able to handle st. Louis and
we would easily beat them but
considering we're just sort of a speed
finesse team and the way the officials I
guess because it's the playoffs are
calling it which once again I don't
really have a problem with it I'd have a
problem with I have a problem the fact
that there's no that there's no there's
no fighting I just you know we should
have a guy up go out there and go kick
the [ __ ] out of one of the Blues so they
calm the [ __ ] down and we just haven't
so why would they stop it's been working
for them so this is what I think if st.
Louis wins this then
I in they're not you know reprimanded
for the way that they're playing then
that just sends the message that this is
the direction to go in and what's going
to be I know it's [ __ ] because the
people that are gonna suffer are not
going to be the [ __ ] dirtbags skating
around with their [ __ ] sticks up
cross-checking people in the [ __ ]
teeth the people who are going to suffer
are the stars of the leagues the
Tarasenko z-- they're going to pay for
it and I that goes all the way back to I
remember back in the day when the
Tennessee Titans when they were still
the Houston Oilers and they got Jerry
Glanville you know and Jerry's big thing
is any any football team that he coached
you know he wanted to he wanted to wear
black you know like the Falcons were
like you know they were like red with
gray pants and white or whatever and he
came there and he changed the black
jerseys because he wanted to be tough or
whatever right and then when he went to
you know so he did that there didn't win
and then he went to [ __ ] Houston he's
like let's change this one to black it's
like Jerry you already stole the [ __ ]
Raiders colors kind of once we can't do
it with two different franchises so he
went out and he got a black satin
[ __ ] Oilers jacket that he would wear
with like the blue red and white logo so
anyway his team took on his personality
and they started calling the Astrodome
the House of Pain meaning you were gonna
go in there and obviously the defense
was gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you and
you were just going to have a painful
[ __ ] afternoon playing the Houston
Oilers and they did that for I don't
know five six seven games before Warren
Moon CFL and NFL Hall of Famer had a
meeting with the defense and said listen
stop saying that [ __ ] stop calling this
place the House of Pain because you know
who has to answer to that me I do I have
the ball every offensive [ __ ] play
and I'm gonna get my ass kicked for your
[ __ ] talkin so shut the [ __ ] up if you
want to inflict some plain just [ __ ]
inflate plane right
so anyway couldn't back to what the st.
Louis Blues are doing I think that
anybody watching this [ __ ] if they if
Saint Louis wins this it's gonna change
hockey it's gonna start going this
direction of like oh okay
this is what the [ __ ] we need to do we
need you know there's no more goons to
really a police [ __ ] or not enough of
them so we'll just start taking runs at
people I don't know it's a very it's a
[ __ ] really bizarre series I can't
really get my head around it it's like
we absolutely dominated them in Game one
and they absolutely dominated us in Game
two and then Game three as far as the
score went we absolutely dominated them
but we played eighty percent in our end
and then Game four like when I say they
dot like physically dominated us like
III honestly thought that the way that
the [ __ ] liberties that they were
taking and the piece of [ __ ] way that
they were playing that after they scored
the empty net goal and there was no
chance of us winning I was like well
that we should go out and just go cross
check one of their players right in the
[ __ ] mouth which is something that I
never say but I was so infuriated
watching that happen to everybody on the
Bruins I don't know it's weird so this
is what I think we need to win Game five
in Game six if it goes to game seven I
just I you know I think we're gonna be
looking like San Jose we're half our
team's in a [ __ ] mass unit I hope I'm
wrong
granted like I said I'm just you know
I'm a stand-up comedian who [ __ ]
skates at a public rink you know one way
counterclockwise she go the other way
all of a sudden I start having problems
so remember I said that the st. Louis
Blues win this thing you're gonna see
their style of play is gonna become the
prototype and the last time that I think
we saw this was the Flyers when the
Flyers were not the best team and then
they went out back when you could fight
and they just dropped the gloves and
just beat the [ __ ] out of people and
they started they won back-to-back cups
I mean I don't know you can't really
compare anybody to the Flyers maybe just
[ __ ] animals they weren't even
playing hockey but I don't hate those
flyer tubes and I don't hate what they
did because what they did the the Golden
Age of their style of play was in the
80s we had the perfect balance of just
some of the greatest goal scorers of all
time and some of the greatest fighters
of all time so I don't get mad at and
also if the Flyers didn't do what they
did in 74 in 75 Paul Newman one of my
favorite actors of all time never signs
on to make the movies slap shot so I
don't have a problem with it and I
really don't have a problem with the st.
Louis Blues it's just a hard thing to
watch as a Bruins fan to watch us get
physically dominated and to try to
continue to play a finesse game I've I
just I don't like I think I got to get
used to that but all of my diehard Bruin
fans from back home are keep telling me
like just you know this is like a boxing
match
we're boxing they're brawling don't get
drawn into it and I'm like okay I I
don't like it I don't like it so we
shall see but unfortunately I mean I
can't complain about working on a movie
but I'm working tonight so I'm actually
gonna miss the game so I'm gonna have to
watch some of the highlights but uh oh
boy I don't know I don't know this has
been a this has been out [ __ ] this
there's no way there's nobody who's
watching this series can actually say
who's gonna win it's so [ __ ] crazy so
here we go you know what would be crazy
is if st. Louis wins this and then
Toronto wins and both of them and I
guess Toronto ends a championship
drought while st. Louis ends a you know
wins their first Stanley Cup
so either way that'll be fun as far as
sports histories go so I mean the st.
Louis Blues one would suck because my
team would lose but you know what are
you gonna do things happen okay you win
some you lose some
all right but having said that go Bruins
we've got to [ __ ] win five and went
six that's it before they take this
sickles out in Game seven you know and
chop literally chop a Bruins head off
and get called from matching penalties
all right
anyway rumor has it I might be off
tomorrow or if that's true I'm gonna try
to do some stand-up this weekend here in
New York City so visit your local comedy
club who knows you might see old
freckles [ __ ] can come around you know
what is great though I told you when I
go to when I go to these whenever I do
these acting gigs how I get through it
the weirdness of it where like as a
comedian if somebody tells me to do 20
minutes I'd do 20 minutes and it takes
20 minutes as an actor if I'm in
something that's going to be 20 minutes
it's gonna take like a month three weeks
or whatever to shoot it I just when I go
down when I go on set am i speaking that
took that's it going right near on set
on set you want to jump on the podcast
at all I know you're busy what I do is I
just I don't bring a wat I don't bring a
watch I don't bring a I don't bring a
phone I have no [ __ ] idea like what
time it is or anything and I'm able to
just sort of [ __ ] plow through it but
today when I go down there it's like the
Bruins game so on so I don't know what
I'm gonna do you know I'm still not
gonna bring one cuz I'm not gonna see
the [ __ ] game anyways do I need to
get all my texts my Massachusetts
friends oh what the [ __ ]
yes here we go dude that's [ __ ] and
then I don't even know what's going on
that's gonna drive me up the [ __ ]
wall so but what is cool about not
bringing my phone is just not being on
the phone and yesterday we had a long
day we had we had a scene at a dinner
table and anytime you see a scene at a
dinner table in a movie I'm telling you
it takes all day cuz there's just so
many angles they have to get in all that
so it took
a long time to shoot so in a good way I
wasn't on my phone at all feel like the
whole day I'll tell you what's hilarious
if you don't text people nobody really
text you and I came out and I had like I
think ten text messages and I was able
to handle all of them with either lol's
or write some business thing back in
like [ __ ] eight minutes and I was
done so I kind of learned something that
I'm not going to apply but I would love
to apply that in my everyday life and
speaking of my everyday life oh here's
my everyday love Oh making her
triumphant return her triumphant return
ever since she's been a mom you know
we've just been we've been to ships
passing in the night yeah exactly
so how you but what do you been up to I
think good yeah right yep William
William William William William I've
been great William no this is you guys
being here those making my date my work
out here nice and nice and easy you guys
should do that all the time like if I
get stand-up gigs in like Dayton right
oh the Quad Cities sure yeah I know you
support me in the fun cities yeah
decided curiosity if with if this thing
was two months in Jacksonville Florida
would you be here jack Jacksonville you
know what maybe because I have a friend
out there that's what I thought nothing
about me why are you so mean but I would
definitely we would definitely come out
for like three weeks no all right
hey did you see in Boston they're gonna
have a straight pride March
yes I saw that [ __ ] ridiculous
of course Boston of course a [ __ ]
course like what is the point what did
what is the point of that I don't know
this is like this is my sober
are they trolling is it that's my thing
if my thing is is if they're doing it
cuz it's all gonna be like to just guys
right it's all gonna be like white guys
out there being like what about us well
I think what they're also petitioning
that the LGB cute XYZ whatever the [ __ ]
it is that they add an S to it for
straight no I'm not spatula I'm waiting
for that's what I'm waiting for them to
be like this is a social experiment to
see how bah-bah-bah which would be
really [ __ ] stupid cuz what do you
need a social experiment in this to be
they're just doing it like honestly when
stuff like this happens you have to
ignore it but it's just impossible media
will always pick it up and they know
that but you got to ignore that [ __ ]
it's like it's it's nothing it's not
it's not even worth getting upset over
although I understand away some people
make it up you're getting a little heat
you're a little [ __ ] stupid why don't
you take your own advice
it's just [ __ ] stupid why don't you
just take your own advice I mean I am
but I mean yeah I had a buddy might text
me today I am so buddy hit me text me
today he goes dude it's just a real
[ __ ] day he texts me cuz it's so I'm
going yeah and he texts me this [ __ ]
thing where it was some flag for people
who are asexual or don't feel feelings
about people but sometimes do in Buffalo
relish you know and he's just sitting
there I was just hours laughing because
you know I've been on this movie thing
so I don't [ __ ] look at my phone so
it's what you get disconnected that
quickly from everybody else
yeah like when you're in it and I'm
looking at my phone then I'm running
around to acting like the sky is falling
but when you don't look at your phone
literally for [ __ ] 12 hours you're
coming out like I'm on Staten Island
yeah it's beautiful
yeah perfect [ __ ] weather and that we
was sitting on the stairs in between
takes and I was saying to one of the
other actors I go this reminds me when I
was a kid and she was mean like yeah I
know right hey just come out here you
just sit down
on a perfect summer day and people would
come out you talk and then we kids
playing in the street and just hanging
out you didn't realize you had your
whole life ahead of you how awesome it
was and then the second I pick up my
phone and ship seven toad if you say
this
what the [ __ ] it isn't their flag like
black and white so it's that that seems
very sort of like symbolic because black
and white it's like straight or not
whereas you know they're their flag the
lgbtq is like the rainbow all inclusive
like however you're feeling nothing Atos
I thought that was more of a fashion
thing it's not like I'm gonna need more
colors than that honey no I think you
know what and I don't even know so I
might be talking out of my ass but I
just felt like I saw that black and
white one and I was like oh I get it
it's very black and white over over here
straight Ville yeah come on yeah there
we go
yeah images heterosexual flags Oh your
first thing that comes up somebody said
the things to just oh of course it's on
some janky ass [ __ ] website that's
someone put together like a black 5
minute white striped flag
oh my god I have to see my opposed fly
forever sexuals I believe the design was
six horizontal stripe Northwest what
obvious references to the rainbow flag
essentially removed of its color yeah I
don't know I don't know oh wait somebody
wrote that February 2001 yeah look at
this [ __ ] you know clipart like in a
website that's going well it's just one
of those ones what are they talk what
people are just talking to each other
Oh like a thread or something yeah I
don't know yeah well us trace five plans
March into controversy super happy fun
America which has applied to the city
good whatever I don't even I'm gonna
take my own advice I don't even want to
give this any airtime Boston planning a
straight pride Boston but oh wait wait
wait okay read this headline it's LG way
we put the its LGBT Pride Month but
three guys in Boston what a permit for a
straight Pride Parade I'm
on a parade okay three people is not a
parade over land is that right you dumb
[ __ ] like come on everybody just relax
ridiculous
nobody's showing up to that Pride Month
kicks off in Boston on Tuesday with a
light event a paint nite a preparation
for a possible and preparation for
possible straight Pride Parade this
summer why can't I march down the street
let me tell you if your boyfriend or
husband is participating in this March
like you really need to reconsider your
relationship I'll just do what I love
about you you know what I love about you
reconsider is you're giving it perfect
you're you're giving the perfect advice
while taking the bait all at the same
time I know he says you just said they
roped me into there's only gonna be
three [ __ ] people there you're
getting worked up over three people yeah
Wow you know what I'm more worked up
over the fact that this is like news
what's gonna happen next Nia are they
gonna cancel the reboot of Will & Grace
three people are gonna have a parade I
mean why is everybody the event to
celebrate the heterosexuality and one of
the nation's most gay friendly cities I
didn't know that look at us it's many
folks funny fun at identity politics or
the political left yeah he's just making
fun of him by Troy he's also organized
free speech quote-unquote rallies and
gun rights administration oh so this is
a [ __ ] wave supremacist I get it free
what what did you just do what did you
just do there you don't know this guy
three eight straight guys I guarantee
you they're [ __ ] white they're gonna
do a thing to poke fun at identity
policy and he wanted to eat all you
sound like a redneck right now three of
speech and a gun rights demonstration it
sound like a redneck right now sue
together you suckas behind that you
sound like a redneck front portal engage
them right now if I was a redneck this
bag
No why can't I be missing that point is
you don't know this guy no I do and he's
gone what I'm seeing in this article
well that was my point yes this is what
people do this open mind oh I get it
come on man like this is a piece of you
man on the right and the left you're
both like sitting here making
assumptions like you know that there's
such that's such [ __ ] it isn't right
and there's wrong and there are people
who are on the wrong side of things and
they're people who are at least trying
to be on the right side of things and
making people feel comfortable and
making people feel included like what do
you [ __ ] care gay people have like a
parade why does that mean that you Albin
you now have to have a parade so like
poke fun and identity Paulo what the
[ __ ] does it even have to do with you
we'll be right back with Nia takes the
bait after these messages
yeah but skins to know taking the bait
I'm standing up for what's right like
what like what does it matter to you you
feel you're a warrior right now people
have a parade that has nothing to do
with you leave it alone you're did you
guys just have to now have your own
break a time snake - it's like you're
being helpful that's what it is you're
being an [ __ ] you're not standing up
for anything that's different not making
a point that's different than hating
people no it is it's a very fine line
it's a very quick this dude is trying to
was trying to work my the free speech
rally in a gun rights demonstration
first of all does a free speech rally
need to exist
you have three special no you don't yes
you do you don't we do you're not free
of consequences from the things that you
say you know ah there it is who could
say whatever you want but you're right
you respond to it which has now become
not just responding to it I'm going to
destroy your ability to now make a
[ __ ] living that is not tit for tat
that is not a debate there is what you
can have a respectful debate where
people feel differently about various
things you're a loud protest where they
tell you to protest now you have to get
a permit they make sure you down the
street and around the block and away
from the cameras
they don't relly does that really make
sense to use that really something like
you need to have we want free speech you
have it you have free speech I don't
need a rap I don't know I would have try
what if I you know you know this is like
not consuming comedians have gotten sued
and lost in Canada and Canada over jokes
yeah like this is this is like people
are in the middle people in the middle
of stand up sets in America at comedy
chat colleges and they shut off the mic
and take the mic on it they don't even
understand the [ __ ] joke it's like
people videotape comedians now and they
try to get thee and all everybody's
trying to do is get you in trouble and
when what that does is it instills fear
and makes people feel oh I don't want to
say that oh I shouldn't say that like
there's people literally look at it like
[ __ ] looking at the office even the
office that's silly
absurd show and everybody loved and in
10 years later people all we could never
we could never get away with that dorky
white people in the middle of [ __ ] I
heard Steve like yeah like Michael Scott
couldn't exists right now couldn't exist
as absurd as that guy I don't know I
mean I kind of get this point but like
he's the hope I don't know the point of
Michael Scott was that he was so she
think he has credibility as the manhood
guy but I also know as someone that's
like my favorite show ever that the
point of Michael Scott was that he was
hilariously out of touch but he had a
huge heart and he'd loved everybody but
he always said the wrong thing just cuz
he was like ignorant about stuff but he
wasn't a bad person you know he just
would say dumb stuff and it was funny
because he was so clueless
the thing with Michael Scott was never
that he was mean or trying to like dig
at somebody or trying to poke fun that
identity I understand but but I'm saying
about this thing with black people here
what's the gay lingo like he was yet
there has been an unbelievable
infringement on free speech since 9/11
okay since 9/11 there's been an
unbelievable infringement like your like
the way you're not allowed to discuss
our foreign policy other than to just
say the standard I support the troops my
thoughts and prayers go out to the
families and the victims that's what
you're allowed to say I see you don't
say that they don't believe in that at
all not that they don't support the
people who are serving but there are
very much against everything that we do
in terms of wars and all that kind of
stuff so I don't I don't know I don't I
don't see it like that I don't see I do
because I what I saw was if you look at
the way comedians and performance acted
during the Vietnam War
they were fearless said whatever the
[ __ ] they wanted right there was an
there was an immediate like what the
people that earn money off of war
learned from Vietnam is that if you if
the media and the public turns on it you
know you're gonna have to leave this
money-making [ __ ] war that you're in
so what they did during I don't was an
actual conspiracy to do it but what they
did since Vietnam was basically all
mainstream media got into the hands of
very few people okay that's why when you
watch fox or you watch CNN
there is no criticism of hey wait a
minute how the [ __ ] we gonna pay it like
now we're talking about starting a war
with Iran and we're completely [ __ ]
bankrupt like how exactly are we go what
is the endgame why are we doing this
you're not allowed to ask any of that
and if you ask any of that that means
that you don't appreciate the troop they
put it all on the [ __ ] tree you don't
like babies
you don't think kids should have ice
cream use you're a social issue should
get the [ __ ] out of here and and
everybody you know this this thing of
like the amount of people going like you
know there's no upside don't say
anything don't say didn't we all not
said anything into like trillions and
trillions of dollars of [ __ ] debt and
we allowed 3500 [ __ ] jerk-offs on a
jungle gym to bankrupt a first world
nation because all of us don't want to
get in trouble and I'm not saying I
don't have I don't have a [ __ ]
solution for any
but you should be able to be like hey
man just out of curiosity how the [ __ ]
we got to pay for this right like I
understand what we were trying to
achieve here but financially the way
we're going about this is is there a
better way to do this if you if you do
any of that why don't you get the [ __ ]
out of the country you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] socials and now in stand-up you
know I told you I was a [ __ ]
Dangerfield and this woman in the crowd
didn't like what I was told she's like
next object nobody wants to hear this
and then of this big [ __ ] walking out
and that I think is just you know she
was like young she was in her 20s and
just grew up on social media and
everybody knew and I'm gonna make a
comment and everything I think and how I
feel and all of my feelings are so
[ __ ] it's like you she was talking to
me like she hired me for her birthday
party right it's like no you came to the
comedy club yeah yeah and sitting there
like like she was [ __ ] Napoleon it's
like I'm off talking about what [ __ ] I
want to talk about yeah and she sat
there like I needed to talk about things
that only she needed to hear and then
she got actually sat there and acted as
though she spoke for everybody and I
think I don't think it's all this big
conspiracy I also think it has to do
with how much content is out there and
all of these shits so then what it
becomes is it becomes like like arguing
and screaming and yelling is the way to
get viewers so that's why any little
[ __ ] dust up like three [ __ ]
jerk-offs having a straight Pride Parade
gets everybody all amped up or somebody
comes up with a [ __ ] flag and
everybody [ __ ] focuses is on that
rather than hey man we're bankrupt and
we're talking about starting another
[ __ ] war just out of curiosity I
think it's at what point at what point
are we just gonna go out of business
over here I mean what there's no way the
way we're running that this country
right now financially is it's beyond
[ __ ] reckless if anybody else as an
individual ran our lives the way they're
running this country right now
financially our credit cards would have
been cut up [ __ ] 30 years ago well I
feel like you can have
multiple things that you are concerned
about so I don't believe in this whole
like why are you concerned about this
when we should be concerned about life
you can be concerned about a multitude
of things you don't think there's
probably already weight but I mean
there's your priorities and like my
priorities might be different but I also
feel like - something like I'm starting
to think more now like I think something
like a straight Pride Parade and poking
fun and identity politics
what the concern is that you've got
people sort of stirring up this thing
where that that even though it seems so
silly and ridiculous and not important
that is informing the minds of people
who feel more empowered to try to like
hurt people who identify a certain way
but who empowered them huh who empowered
them wind-powered who who empowers those
people empowers what people what do you
think the straight pride people it's
three [ __ ] people and people are
screaming and yelling like it's 3
million people right because I think you
know it's a touchy thing it's like this
is the type of stuff where you know it's
it's I feel like it's a fine line
between like I should be proud to be
straight and like [ __ ] you you f word or
you [ __ ] or some kind of like other
slander and it and that can often lead
to violence and death - death - death to
them I know it's like that's why I talk
to people applying for the people three
people applying for a permit I don't act
like the Third Reich just got back
together and then you give them
everything that they want and then you
know what who hears it those [ __ ]
people who already think those things
but again so in a way as you guys are
handing out flyers I don't think that
people should ever stop speaking up for
what they believe in and what they feel
like is harmful to them and when it
comes to these tiny people doing
something but again I what makes it
harmful is a million people who wouldn't
do it letting no announcing to people
who didn't even know that it's [ __ ]
existed that it now exists but also I'm
not going to tell people who are
[Music]
hurt or triggered or offended or
whatever the word is by the very idea
this that they shouldn't be upset about
that I'm not gonna do that to them
because if they are upset about it if
this drums up feelings like oh my god
this is exactly what my grandma or my
dad or whatever said then I'm not gonna
tell them then meanwhile we're gonna
start another [ __ ] war and be even
more bankrupt and wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
yeah it's literally like our house is on
fire and you're going you know we need a
new toaster I mean what are we doing
here it's like literally we're talking
about you know we're gonna go under at
some point we're gonna go under I mean
how much it's some [ __ ] point I
watched I watched Russia we all watched
Russia go bankrupt it happens okay I
know but I just don't think that it is
your or my place to tell people what
they should be worked up about and you
should be more concerned about this
that's just my opinion especially when
it comes to this I'm not very wife said
this before I'm not very well-versed in
any of those issues I tell you something
why this is why global warming's will
not be solved because people are gonna
be sitting around talking about
gender-neutral bathrooms when they're
not gonna have a place to [ __ ] and put
them is like there are priorities okay
and I would say I mean that's like
saying you know do you have priorities
in your personal life is just like well
getting toothpaste is just as much as
just as important is paying the life
insurance bill this month no I don't
really think you can simplify it like
that you're such a straight pride flag
you're so black-and-white because what
you're arguing what you're arguing
exists within this thing this large
thing that's gonna go under okay so it's
like you're you're on a boat that's
sinking and you're talking about what
what color we should paint one of the
cabins rather than trying to plug up the
[ __ ] we're not going to have a boat
do you understand I'm trying to be as
sensitive and
open-minded to people as I can okay I
give up
I absolutely I give up I can't I give up
with [ __ ] people in like I just don't
understand like they I have problems i
got problems in my [ __ ] life but
nothing is more important right now to
me then I would say global warming and
the financial [ __ ] situation in this
country and that's fine like I'm not
because all of this [ __ ] all of this
[ __ ] and how would you feel if I was
like that's not what's important just
what you would say as human beings
rights and no I'm letting you have that
thing that's important to you and not
telling you that it I know but I'm not
to something but I'm not saying what
you're saying is wrong I'm saying what
you're saying it is a circle that exists
in this giant circle that's gonna pop
and then it's just gonna be tethered to
nothing so there's no reason to fix the
[ __ ] roof if the foundation is gonna
collapse like I said I feel like there's
people who are probably more what do you
call it I don't know what the word is
better at figuring that stuff out
no Nia because what is happening is
we're all screaming and yelling like
they will be more arguments in the world
in this country about three [ __ ]
people wanting to have a straight Pride
Parade and versus when was the last time
you saw Twitter blow up about how much
debt were in but also Waits gets back to
the environmental thing are they're not
like hardcore environmentalists and like
you know the pair of support and all
these things that people have been
working on about saving the end right
it's not like it's not being tended to
by people who are in charge or
knowledgeable about that stuff is it not
so is it not your responsibility to try
to use less water bottles but nobody's
doing that nobody's doing that no Pete
Beck does Fame [ __ ] people you'll go
to a gay pride parade and the [ __ ]
thing ends and there's like a zillion
[ __ ] water bottles on the [ __ ]
ground it's hilarious it's like there's
not gonna be there's not gonna need to
be any pride if anything cuz we're not
gonna [ __ ] be here anymore
but if that's what you're getting from
like the gay pride parade then you've
completely missed the point
no I'm seeing the irony in it but like
again what does that have to do with the
gay pride parade see you guys sittin
here having a parade about gay rights
with them I'm what I'm saying is that
would just sew up our own [ __ ] asses
about about bathrooms and and and and
support the troops and [ __ ] America
and all of this [ __ ] we're bankrupt near
we're [ __ ] bankrupt and we're talking
about starting another [ __ ] war so
all of this [ __ ] that we're [ __ ]
sitting here losing our [ __ ] mind
about it doesn't exist it's okay if you
just viewed this country is a big
[ __ ] house and we're yelling about
the wallpaper and the carpeting and all
that and meanwhile the [ __ ] thing on
the other side of the house is on fire
although other foundation is gonna
collapse to sit there and say that that
you know like if we don't if its global
warming thing okay is not [ __ ] hoax
is an absolute truth then all of these
issues that we have are going to be non
issues when the ocean rises up and
swallows us all if you were
part of that community I think you would
feel very differently but you're not so
it's very easy for you to sit back and
tell people what they should and should
not focus on I am NOT saying that you
shouldn't focus on it you missing my
point
my [ __ ] point is there's not even
remotely the same level of passion for
how much [ __ ] debt we're in and what
the [ __ ] are we doing maybe you just
haven't found like your tribe in that or
something maybe you need to be on like
environmental Twitter when that's kind
of what all they talk about I don't know
because I because Nia what you're
talking about is a subset of a subset of
[ __ ] people I'm saying the mainstream
Nia the mainstream people who are
[ __ ] looking at means in doing all of
this [ __ ] we're the ones that I don't
know I give up I you know I I you know
something I don't even know where the
[ __ ] this thing even went all I know is
that our ability as hew of every
different human being to live on this
planet is equally as to survive is
equally as important as I don't know
what I don't know what and I never said
that those other issues were not
important I'm just saying I just wish
there was the same level of [ __ ]
passion existed like Doug I don't
understand how in 29 I don't understand
how how is war legal where else it'd
have run around that flat-screen TVs and
say knowledge should do if you actually
looked at the [ __ ] footage that they
don't show over here about what the [ __ ]
happens in war and you see these [ __ ]
people who didn't do anything pull all
their children out of rubble dead you
know they don't they that's the type of
[ __ ] they used to show in the news they
don't show that anymore
they don't show it anymore okay all
right Nia before you leave okay okay can
I make a video of you of throwing a
water ball and haven't landing on top
you know up right where all starts
screaming and that's what the [ __ ] we'll
do all right
it's great to be back all right that's
the podcast everybody well I have to I
got it they're gonna pick me up here so
all right 42 minutes you guys got extra
[ __ ] that that turned into [ __ ]
Meet the Press alright listen to the
music and enjoy the rest of the the
greatest hits podcast its Christ that
got so [ __ ] heated I forgot to read
the advertisement you know you think I
was I would be old enough to just
realize when someone is just not gonna
agree with me to just [ __ ] stop I
don't know if I'll ever [ __ ] figure
that out but you know what me figuring
that out is not more important than us
fiscally and [ __ ] environmentally
everything's a priority frame bridge
everybody Father's Day is around the
corner and dad doesn't want another pair
of socks out Jesus Christ you know when
you see Mother's Day all this [ __ ] that
they want you to buy him you know I
[ __ ] go into Whole Foods alright with
their genetically altered horse [ __ ]
that they try to pass off as organic
food right I go in there cuz what what
else am I gonna go huh there's no other
[ __ ] game in town anymore so I
[ __ ] go in there and they got this
sign advertising Father's Day and it
literally says it's a picture of a
chicken kabab and it just says hey
nothing says Father's Day like meat on a
stick I gotta buy you jewels and all you
got to do is get me a [ __ ] kebab
anyway
the perfect gift is already on your
phone just uploaded just upload your
phone and order by Sunday June 9th June
9th you got order by June 9th but come
on now this is your dad okay for
guaranteed free delivery and time for
Father's Day just go to frame bridge
calm and upload your photo preview your
item in any frame style choose your
favorite or get free recommendations
from their talented designers the expert
team at frame bridge will custom frame
your item and deliver your finished
piece straight to you or when they can
deliver it to dad in time for Father's
Day when you place your order on by
Sunday June 9th
I missed a word in there somewhere
instead of a hundreds you'll pay at a
traditional framing store their prices
start
39 bucks all shipping is pretty plus my
listeners will get 15% off their first
order at frame bridge comm when they
used my code Barbie you are our I've
used these people got some great frames
photos of when I took my lovely wife who
never agrees with me and my beautiful
daughter to Europe last year and we have
them right underneath the TV so thank
you Frank bridge have a great time with
this I stand by these guys or ladies or
they's or straight fried people all
right Dollar Shave Club dude it's easy
to get caught up in your daily routine
feeling like you're on all our autopilot
that sometimes you forget to take care
of yourself well Jolly shave club makes
it easy to take care of yourself when
that happens their quality products help
you look feel and smell your best you
can get everything you need from Dollar
Shave Club without going to the store
there are executive razor there dr.
calves is easy shave and face cleanser
is the best way to refresh your morning
routine and right now you can get a
dollar shave club status set for just
five dollars off okay it comes with all
the [ __ ] I just said the executive
Raiders shave butter and face cleanser
you're gonna love it as much as I do get
your starter set for just five bucks at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash burn and okay
last but not least butcher box this
month butcher box is offering free bacon
for life sign up now and you'll get one
package of the best tasting baking fruit
bacon free and every box for the life of
your subscription butcher box bacon is
whole 30 approve uncured nitrate and
sugar free right now new members will
get a package of beige bacon for free in
every box for the life of your
subscription plus you'll get $20 off
your first box every month butcher box
delivers 100% grass-fed grass-finished
beef free-range organic chicken and my
favorite heritage breed pork and wild
alaskan salmon directly to your door the
incredible quality of butcher box meat
starts with the commitment to humanely
raised that are never fed antibiotics
antibiotics or hormones there's no
easier way to get high-quality meat that
you can trust there's no commitment you
can cancel anytime to receive your $20
off your
first box and a package of free bacon
and every box for the life of your
subscription go to butcher box calm /
burg are Interborough at checkout go now
it's a limited time offer hey what's
going on it's bill burr and it is the
Monday morning podcast for June 6th 2011
how the hell are you how is your day
going are you on vacation like I am yes
sir I am on vacation but before I get to
talking about what a great fun
ass-fucking time I've been having for
the last few days I need to address the
Boston Bruins for half a second all
right do you know what the Bruins need
okay they need Larry Bird or someone of
his ilk God knows there's not a lot of
them to walk into that [ __ ] locker
room okay and he needs to give that
speech that he gave way back in the day
when we were getting [ __ ] our asses
kicked by the Lakers and Larry Bird
what's [ __ ] went on TV or whatever
he's getting interviewed and he's
sitting there with his [ __ ] pasty
torso and his little prepubescent
[ __ ] mustache you know its cleft
palate upper lip whatever he's covering
up I don't know every man's got some
secrets but he said he sat there after
getting his ass kicked by the [ __ ]
Lakers the Celtics he said we played
like a bunch of damn sissies out there
we played like a bunch of sissies he
just
saying it we played like a bunch of
sissies what happened in the next game
what happens the next day Oh [ __ ]
Kurt Rambis comes down the damn Court he
gets [ __ ] clothesline by Kevin McHale
and I believe Larry Bird I can't
remember I don't have the highlight in
front of me I'm on vacation I don't have
time to do that [ __ ] and that turned the
host series around all right now I was
watching that game [ __ ] too and the
people commentating they're all great
they're all great Millbury I like all
those guys but they kept saying I'll
tell you Boston fans gotta be mad at
what the [ __ ] his name burrows I
didn't know the guy's goddamn name and
never heard him didn't get suspended cuz
in the first game he bit patrice
bergeron finger okay and they just kept
going I'll tell you Boston fans I'll
tell you they they gotta be upset right
now they really got to be upset you know
they got to be upset that this guy
didn't get suspended and you know what
happens I guarantee you on Boston sports
radio there's a bunch of Bruins fans
going you know I'm upset because
[ __ ] wasn't suspended they literally
tell you what to think that [ __ ] guy
he shouldn't have got suspended what he
did was not suspend a ball it was just
sort of bizarre it was something like a
six-year-old or I get toddler would do
that's why I after that's why there was
no huge response after he did you know
if you [ __ ] slam someone face for it
first into the board you take a cheap
shot the whole team's pile on he trying
to kick the [ __ ] out you bite somebody
people are just standing around like
dude what the [ __ ]
that's what patrice bergeron was doing
he's skating off the ice he looks at a
friend of isn't the friend of his day
because he [ __ ] bit me I don't think
it was suspended well maybe you would
make the guy wear a dress for the first
period of the game too maybe that all
right but that does not address the
issues that the Bruins have right now
the the [ __ ] issue is that they're
playing
they're playing soft they make in
Vancouver look like this tough physical
team now I totally respect Vancouver
they are a beast of a team with goal
scorers snipers okay Luongo I would give
you know I'll give him 8 out of 10 stars
because that guy can get rattled all
right but they're not a physical team
when I look down their bench there's
nobody there that looks intimidating
it's a bunch of red bearded douchebags
like me every other guy in that team
looks like me I'm not intimidating but
the way the Bruins are play I don't get
it Chara is getting pushed all over the
[ __ ] ice I'm getting sick of it so
I'm hoping that that's what is going on
right now and in game 3 we come out we
stop playing like a bunch of goddamn
sissies and we hit these goal scorers
that's all they are they're a team of
goal scorers there's nobody tough on
their team stop getting pushed around
did you see what happened when you
checked [ __ ] what's-his-face there
god damn it I'm so bad with the names
the [ __ ] is his name the guy from
Livonia Michigan and he used to play
angry and now he doesn't get angry
anymore and now he's having a career
year [ __ ] oh he's not one of the sin
deeds he's [ __ ] I can never remember
names I'm the worst that [ __ ] guy he
got hit and all of a sudden he gets up
slowly skates off the ice that's what
you do that's what you do a goal scorers
you slam him into the boards legally
that's what you do you don't just stand
there give up the blue line oh wow look
at them they're so good at path thing
I'm getting sick of it
alright you're making the will makin
Vancouver look like they're the [ __ ]
Flyers they're not alright this is
exactly what we did against Montreal we
made Carey Price look like the second
coming a [ __ ] Patrick wah because we
kept taking slap shots from the [ __ ]
red line with nobody in front right at
his goddamn pancreas another save by
Carey Price okay the bro it's gotta be
buckle it'll shut up and what do we do
we went down oh - do we have it in us
again
I don't [ __ ] know I don't but I would
like if we would actually return a
couple of checks every once in a while
they've actually been to great [ __ ]
games and I'd be way more excited about
it if if we weren't down Oh to you know
all these [ __ ] douche bag Canuck fans
we haven't said [ __ ] to me all year my
Twitter's blowing up after they win
games by the way no no [ __ ] talk before
the game you know then they give me a
bunch of [ __ ] you know walking around
with their chest puffed out because they
want to wonder nothing game it's [ __ ]
annoying then they're giving me [ __ ] cuz
I'm not texting during the finals I'm
sorry my team hasn't been there in 20
years I don't want to come up with
clever [ __ ] during the [ __ ] game
alright okay enough of that [ __ ] um so
anyways I'm on our vacation and you know
a lot of people when they go on vacation
neiha could you not put away the plates
so loudly please I don't know if you
guys can hear that that's very
disturbing I'm taking I'm taping the
podcast right now
hey how nice is it to be in like a house
huh it's very nice thank you you know
what sometimes I call her over and she
wants to talk other times she doesn't
I think she's annoyed with me even on
vacation I can only get like six hours
sleep cuz halfway through like the night
all of a sudden my brains like how come
you didn't sign up for crab soccer in
seventh grade and then I got to walk
around and think about that [ __ ]
what's crab soccer I don't know vacation
in New England someone will explain it
to you just reminded me of a [ __ ] up
story we used to have this gym coach
this guy was the [ __ ] and you know he
drank a little bit and he gambled a
little bit and it was the 80s so you
didn't really hide it he come in with
his red nose and I remember we would
play it was [ __ ] awesome we would
play football and we had gym class on
Mondays so there was always Monday Night
Football so basically what he would do
whoever was playing Monday Night
Football let's say it was the Browns
versus the Lions he'd divide up the gym
class and he'd go you guys are the
Browns and you guys are the Lions and
whoever wins I'm gonna bet this on the
game and he
this big wad of cash and we thought he
was filthy stinking rich so anyways
we're playing Krabs
and this kid scores a goal right and
this guy used to like the guy was the
[ __ ] he used to like announce the games
as you were playing him he'd be like oh
[ __ ] look at Barratt defense he's all
over the place and it just gets you
amped up the guy was the greatest gym
teacher / human being ever so anyways
this kid scores a goal alright
then he scores another goal and he's
like he's flipping out holy [ __ ] and
then he yells if you score another goal
I'm gonna buy you an Atari which in our
world is seventh-graders cost like 9
zillion dollars so needless to say that
the kid scores the [ __ ] goal and he
starts flipping out because the gym
coach is just hyping him up just kept
screaming over and over again I'm gonna
buy you an Atari I'm gonna buy you an
Atari and we're all going nuts he's
gonna buy him an Atari next week Hey
Dude he buy the Atari nah not yet not
yet but he's gonna week after that he
ever get you get that Atari and I hasn't
got it to me yeah he never got it for
you no typical gambler he's all great
he's all great he builds y'all up and
then right when you need him he [ __ ]
walks away from you but the best goddamn
gym coach I ever had was that even
remotely interesting well you know what
I don't give a [ __ ] cuz I'm on vacation
technically I'm not even supposed to be
doing this I'm supposed to be on
vacation what did you guys do you called
me back to the office now I'm shuffling
around looking for those papers I forgot
my wife and kids are out in the car I
thought of God he just can't leave his
job for more than three days anyway so
you probably wondering where I'm at I'm
actually at I don't know I travel all
the [ __ ] time okay I travel all the
time and I'm always going to airports
and you guys know how I feel about that
and I always get on a plane and I'm
always sitting next
some fatty right and they always look at
me a little you make it these smaller
every year no no sir no well maybe a
little bit but in general you keep
getting fatter and I know it's a disease
anyways yeah there's always some fatties
spilling into my goddamn seat okay or I
get the aisle and then there's some
[ __ ] douche with a weak bladder and
every time I start to nod off with my
heavy head and it starts to [ __ ] it you
know I just start nodding off and as my
heavy heads going forward I start having
dreams about being slapped in the back
of the neck oh that's how I should have
done that joke and I didn't realize it's
actually just the weight of my head see
what I did I front-end loaded that one
with the punch line you guys just
learned a little something for all you
people who send me emails about how to
do stand-up comedy here's rule number
one don't put the punch line before the
setup oh geez
anyways so I decided I don't want to go
to the goddamn airport but I'd like to
get away from my apartment so I'm after
years of living out here and everybody
telling me how great Big Bear Mountain
or a big bear summit or Big Bear [ __ ]
Polo Grounds and Lake whatever the [ __ ]
you call this place I decided to come up
here rented a little [ __ ] cabin slash
house and I feel like I'm in New
Hampshire right now it's awesome it's
[ __ ] cold out the water is freezing I
went on a hike yesterday I felt like I
was gonna get hypothermia this ladies
and gentlemen is the vacation of a
redhead you know and fellow redheads out
there freckled face [ __ ] gingers
whatever the hell you want to call us
stop trying to be like regular people
you know everybody wants to go someplace
warm right they go down the Caribbean
and then you show up just blistering in
the goddamn Sun why are you doing that
to yourself
you know and then people just sitting
there going yeah that's them you can't
get any color at all
do I mean I'm like white but you're just
wow look at your legs I'm sorry those
are just you just stand-in there like a
[ __ ] freak don't do that to yourself
that's not the vacation of redhead a
redhead goes from mild climate to
severely cold climate that's that's how
I feel my next vacation is gonna be in
the Yukon Territories you know and I'm
gonna get some snowshoes and get one of
those Eskimo jackets right and I'm gonna
walk across the tundra my little red
nose so anyways we're up here and Big
Bear [ __ ] Lake and I decided I want
to go I wanted to go on this hike two
days ago and you know
Nia's the exact opposite of me she can
sleep until the cows come home she's a
relaxed beautiful person I am a a
psychopath who's totally wound up so I'm
up at like 5:00 in the morning and I
want to go on a hike she doesn't want to
go so I say [ __ ] it I'm going right it
was more like 9:00 in the morning right
which is 5:00 in the morning when you're
on vacation so I walk into the goddamn
woods and this isn't like hiking in LA
this is the real deal like they have
bears they have mountain lions and and
I'm by myself and I wasn't really
thinking I go hiking in LA by myself all
the [ __ ] time so I wasn't thinking
about anything but I gotta tell you the
second I got into the forest this isn't
the woods this is the forest this
overwhelming feeling of being watched
just [ __ ] came over me you know this
is what it's like walking in a forest
okay at first you recognize the animals
when you first get in you're like oh
yeah look at look at the pile ants oh
that's a squirrel Hey look a little
chipmunk right then you get about a
quarter mile in and then that's the
first time you see something movie like
dude what the [ __ ] was that is that a
dog a little dog with a fat tail and
then you get this feeling you're like
wow that thing was running around like
it's nervous that means somebody some
than else is bigger that eats that and
then there's something bigger than that
that eats that and you know the deal and
I started hearing Bill Curtis his voice
in my head you know his girlfriend
didn't get up so he decided to go hiking
alone around 7:30 that evening when Bill
didn't return Nia started getting
worried and that's when they use
horrific words like remains you know
they find my torn jacket one of my legs
just laying on the [ __ ] path that's
when I started so I overrode my ego and
I said [ __ ] this and I turn back around
and I immediately was like I'm gonna get
a knife if I'm gonna go in here by
myself I at least need a knife I'm gonna
get one of those big [ __ ] Daniel
Boone stabbed a grizzly bear right in
the [ __ ] throat
right so I go to the fish and tackle
place down there but whatever the hell
it is the sporting good place and I said
yeah listen I'm going on a hike I want a
knife just getting freaked out that I'm
gonna get eaten by a mountain lion and
the guy's like nah you don't want a
knife you know you want a knife you're
gonna you got to get in close with a
knife I was thinking about that how hard
a grizzly bear can you know that by Anik
bitch-slap that they have well your
[ __ ] head spins around and you break
your neck just imagine me still being
able to hold onto the knife you know the
average NFL running back if he gets
stuck by Ray Lewis fumbles the football
I'm going to be able to hang onto this
knife taking a [ __ ] [ __ ] slap from a
grizzly bear it's gonna fall on the
ground and then it's gonna rip my face
off and then I'm gonna be on Oprah
talking about how I feel blessed that it
ripped my face off because now I know
what's important in life
right isn't what there's not what they
always do after somebody gets their face
ripped off or they get burnt to a crisp
and then they just sit there you know I
realize what's important life is
actually the best thing that ever
happened to me I took everything for
granted it's just like look it's amazing
that that that's how they feel because I
would not feel that way I would [ __ ]
be like not I would be lying to
everybody in the hospital that I felt
great and I felt blessed and I would
then climb
onto the top of the hospital and I would
just roll off you hear what I'm saying
people I would not do well with that
challenge you know they all the
religious people say that that the Lord
only challenges those that he feels are
strong enough I'll tell you right now
that's why I still have a face because
he knows I'm a big [ __ ] anyway so the guy
goes listen you know you don't want a
knife
what you want is some pepper spray I go
pepper spray he goes now he goes this is
this is this is like bear pepper spray
and I'm looking I got the package right
here it says grizzly tough pepper spray
and there's a picture of a bear
counter-assault bear deterrent see so
they're already given in with this
product that you're gonna get a salted
it's not a salt preventer it's counter
assault because basically the goddamn
bear is gonna be coming at you so fast
you know and those things can't stop on
a dime they're like a giant SUV they're
gonna keep gonna hit him with that
[ __ ] pepper spray and it's gonna do a
barrel roll right over you
you feel lucky it's gonna keep [ __ ]
going so anyways he says this [ __ ] is
actually strong enough to blind a
[ __ ] human being but evidently not a
bear which doesn't make sense to me
because like I said as much as I can
understand that a bear can bitch-slap me
down off a [ __ ] Mountain you know an
eyeballs an eyeball right you poke a
bear in the eye he's gonna do that
little [ __ ] you know that little
dance you know the I got poked in the
eye dance even a bear's gonna do that so
anyway so I got this [ __ ] cost me 50
bucks right so I got this [ __ ] and then
I went on a hike yesterday with Nia up -
what was it Bertha summit Bertha peak
Nia yeah Bertha peak which was like a
two-and-a-half hour goddamn hike at
least for us I know some douche from Big
Bear is gonna write in do actually I
could do it in 45 minutes can
yeah well go ahead they're [ __ ] Tonto
have a good time so I buy this [ __ ]
right and what do I do
I forget it like an [ __ ] so then I
just you know I said I [ __ ] at this two
of us you know he is a lot more curvier
than I am she'll probably look like a
better cut of meat I'll be finding what
come here Nia come over here let's talk
about the hike real quick and then I'll
dismiss you coming into this studio
dude I'll say this is how much this is
how much of a [ __ ] redhead I am is
that not only do I want to come up here
to this freezing cold lake we actually
have a jacuzzi here and I and Nia
convinced me to get into this [ __ ] two
nights ago and even that was too hot for
me it wasn't even that hot oh I can't
handle it I can't [ __ ] breathe I
can't I hate that I hate huh I hate
having a hot shower
I hate all it I hate the Sun I don't
like heat in general I like being up
here where it's [ __ ] cold okay
I like how you just said that like like
I'm acting like you were challenging me
it's okay it's okay to like cold things
you know what I don't like about this
place I don't like how every cabin you
ever rent had like it's like whenever
you go into the bathroom there's no heat
whatsoever
you know now that I've bitched about how
I like you know hate the heat but I
don't like that you go in there right to
relieve yourself and like your shirt
your shirt is blowing in the breeze and
every one of these [ __ ] cabins it's
always like a story dude my grandfather
built it back in the 20s no it isn't no
what is it look it's got wood on the
ceilings it's got a moose head above us
this is a cabin it's got a sled hanging
from the ceiling it's got two fireplaces
yeah within sight of each other this is
a cabin but it's a backyard look I'm not
saying there's dirt floors and the
remains of Abe Lincoln in the corner
all right but if we went to look at this
goddamn thing would you call this thing
a house like if you were looking for a
house would you be like it seems more
like a cabin
I see what you're saying but Jesus
trying to get a woman to agree with you
if you want to hear something that this
guy wrote it this guy wrote it in wrote
in all the way from Afghanistan let me
see if I can find this here it's
overrated underrated this is a classic
here right overrated
all right brother I got one for you
overrated trying to have a logical
argument with a woman you're dating now
just wait do I need to be here for this
yeah yeah because you need to balance it
out so this doesn't come off as totally
misogynistic all right what you don't
have to be here no go ahead
all right just come on here be fun have
fun all right overrated trying to have a
logical argument with a woman you're
dating it never ceases to amaze me every
time I overhear some [ __ ] complaining
about some chick that won't listen I
won't listen to him and argues with them
all the time
any veteran dude who's been with the
chick over 48 hours knows that they
don't stay on topic and they don't think
logically they aren't trying to fix [ __ ]
it's an emotional thing with them so why
anyone thinks they can talk to a chicken
that mindset is beyond me the way I see
it most guys go one of two routes when
presented with an angry [ __ ] guy seems
enlightened right yeah exactly why
should I listen to anything this [ __ ]
[ __ ] has to say don't let him make
you mad he's throwing you off your game
anyways either they choose the path of
least resistance saying yeah over and
over again and nodding and gazing into
oblivion a lot of guys do that those are
the henpecked guys right yeah because
they know whatever they say won't make a
difference or they pander to their petty
weak emotions and sensitivities by
talking slowly at a dull whisper trying
to come and appease them both methods
have their benefits however I'd like to
offer a third Avenue if I may
I've been faithfully married seven years
now and it works so far not that I'm an
expert but here you go here's his
his third one alright first like any
competitive dude you beat them at their
own game
when they come at you saying something
like why is this stock on the ground and
I told you to put it bla bla bla in that
[ __ ] whiny I wanna fight voice wagging
their finger and cocking their heads
sideways are you this guy in a reality
show or is this I was wife reacts
anyways you just reply in your loudest
tone whatever the [ __ ] the last thing
that pissed you off was and as you say
it you keep eye contact and walks
straight up to him so basically if you
said why is it why are these socks on
the ground I'm supposed to my loudest
voice go and not break eye contact walk
right up to you be like what oh wait
he's not done yet this is the beginning
this is the first quarter okay look let
the game plan unfold here all right what
the hell am I lost my place usually this
will startle them as they come back no
come on you gotta listen as they come
back this is like they tell you what to
do when approaching a bear or something
like that okay make a lot of noise I'm
here I'm here as they come back with
what as they come back with what does
that have to do with whatever we're
arguing about you just pull down your
pants and start jacking your dick while
they stand there with that dumb confused
look on their face Lea come on you got
to be back here for the reactions
alright so and while they try it no this
is obviously Jay okay maybe this is
forward thinking let me let me finish
here this is a new strategy and while
they try to regain whatever thought they
had in that scatterbrain skill you just
keep going to town not saying a word if
they talk to you till completion you
just say thank you that's about what
that argument was worth and you walk
away as you leave pick up the sock or
whatever and toss it in the hamper there
you go that's that's his thing well if
you stop what's it
yeah yes everybody's happy now he's
joking obviously somebody who's
pandering to your over the top the
completely ridiculous misogynistic
statements okay on a weekly basis on
this [ __ ] podcast she's trying to
impress you by coming up with I've seen
this time why don't you do the dishes
wait a minute let me wait a sec coffee
on up no this is just some copycat fan
I'm supposed to take this seriously like
this is a real thing next anyways so he
said bill your way we're dealing with
women is pretty good but it's
passive-aggressive I don't even know
what he's talking about and I know how
you feel about that [ __ ] about being
passive-aggressive even if you're doing
it to maintain the high road for your
future breakup why does it matter if the
what does it matter if the relationship
is over I don't know what he thinks my
strategy is anyways he said you might as
well say [ __ ] it and go out in a blaze
of glory granted I know about losing
your cool and [ __ ] like that but in the
end it just builds up and leads to a
bigger blow up you end up staring at the
ceiling or yelling as you drive in the
car thinking damn I should have come
back with this or that no [ __ ] that
no matter how witty or snappy your
comeback is it wouldn't have made any
difference because that [ __ ] isn't
gonna listen the only thing you wouldn't
know this guy's happily married
the only thing yeah you don't sound
happily married letting it get you're
letting this guy get to you he's totally
winning right now you're getting mad he
said to pull out his dick and jacket to
be funny yeah that's that's what and you
know what you doing you're being a fun
sponge that totally isn't really taking
it seriously like that lady on NPR lady
who I talked to the other day to hide
this gig and I was talking about Arnold
Schwarzenegger and she just goes I don't
think that situation is funny at all
right so of course that really he
doesn't think it's funny at all
well it doesn't divert me so I just plow
into my [ __ ] material and it's just
dead silence and the other two comics
are laughing so she goes I don't find
that funny at all I go well you know I
always all my jokes I usually end up
losing half the
by being wait a minute she goes I always
and I always end up losing half the
crowd and this is the NPR egghead
response she goes actually I'm a third
of the crowd but it was I was hyping
about yeah so I didn't say anything I
wanted to be like oh she did the math
she ended the interview when we when we
ended the interview she goes okay and
that's I'm so-and-so and this has been
how to build a birdhouse with the
special comedy edition whatever the
stupid NPR story was then she and she
goes okay guys thanks for thought she
goes yeah that wasn't as funny as I
thought it's gonna be Jackie said that
to us yeah yeah because you're actually
thinking that this guy is gonna like is
happily married for seven years and he
goes up and he screams in his wife's
face while like she's a grizzly bear and
then takes his dick out and jacks it
occasionally to completion see you know
what it is what is what it really is is
that i annoy the [ __ ] out of you and I
my views about women are so [ __ ]
annoying to you that the second this guy
started talking you you were you weren't
yelling at him you were yelling at me
I'll [ __ ] yell at you too so get it
off your chest problem you woke this
great guy all tired
[ __ ] rented out a cabin by the lake
to house it's a house I'll go with that
really don't don't get off topic here oh
I want to know what is your goddamn
problem with me nose in my ear I want to
sleep well because it's the Monday
morning podcast I have to do it Monday
morning the title doesn't make any sense
my Monday morning listeners by the way
not yours your selfish [ __ ] my morning
go ahead so that's what I was saying I
know you wanted to be on the podcast so
I was saying you know it's gonna get a
little loud out there yeah all right
fine yeah yeah one of these days the day
you realize that you don't have a leg to
stand on in this relationship we're
gonna get
so much better how great was the cowboy
steak house down the street
Oh delicious yeah the [ __ ] ribs yeah
I'm gonna hype it you know what yeah I
don't have any advertising this week but
I'm gonna [ __ ] hype this place it's
called the cowboy steak house the cowboy
steak us on I forgot the street I don't
know what the big bear lake yeah big
bear like you can't miss it it's one of
three restaurants up here so we come
walking in right immediately you know
you know they got like the country music
just a good never meanin no harm but
laid a better blue they got all this
country [ __ ] songs played Sonia
obviously gets nervous yeah right places
like that yeah yeah and everyone's gonna
stop and look at me
tarnation she doing in here yeah even
though we're in California yeah but no
but no but that's the thing though is
the second you get outside the cities is
it gets very it can get very Macon
Georgia quickly and sometimes it doesn't
like up here it doesn't these people are
all cool thing yeah everybody's very
cool but we went in there and you were
like you were asking me if you thought
you know if this is a second I smelled
that food I was like this this is gonna
be good mm-hmm that was delicious yeah I
saw that big fat guy eating the ribs oh
yes how fat was that guy he was pretty
fat he had a whole thing to himself we
split it he's one of those guys who's so
fatty wears shorts all year round pans
are too constricting dude I don't get
cold why would you you [ __ ] walrus
look at you your biggest prop Mike
that's he's the only guy here I get
attacked by a polar bear yeah all right
so anyways so this guy actually asked me
what my strategy is with women well I'm
gonna tell you this I actually I'm doing
a giant chunk of material on this I
disagree with you women
argue stay on topic if they're right all
right if they're wrong that's when they
do all the diversionary tactics and they
try to make it about something else and
if you're not going for it
if you don't fall for their diversionary
tactics then their last
effort is trying to just to try to make
you mad like what you did to me
yesterday when he kept saying I was
acting like a baby because you knew I
was right you're right he's got at once
you're acting like a baby
I said at once he said it more than once
no I did not know then you came in the
bedroom and you said why are you acting
like a bait you're throwing a temper
tantrum I walked away calm and cool then
why did I hear the door closed
because it's a [ __ ] solid object
because it's a door doors make noise
when you open and close I didn't slam it
wow what happened to slamming the door
no I did land the door I didn't slam the
door whatever and you said that's not
that wouldn't work in a debating class
we're not in a debating class we're on
you're on my podcast a little low five
punch all right you know what you don't
have to be here I don't I don't need to
take that on my vacation how [ __ ] up
was that hike we went on yesterday we
went oh my god that hike was you're
ridiculous yeah and you know what you
were great for the first 90% that last
10% I don't want to go and you started
doing that toddler thing were you making
your arms go limp and your head was
going back I was frustrated admit yeah
it was a long tiring difficult hike
beautiful but you know fine you know
what I realized that crash and we
survived I'm gonna have to be the guy
that makes something happen what are you
talking about I'm talking about that
last 10% of the hike when you tapped out
you tapped out yeah but I kept going I
just got quiet why cuz I kept urging you
on like a [ __ ] team leader Wow I
didn't like ridiculous hike I told you
we should do like a little moderate
there was nothing big about it please
my feet were killing me by the end of it
yeah I wear those oh you watch a
middle-aged middle-aged white guys wear
the new bet the gray New Balance with
the inserts what do people put on their
foot and they look like a foot and it's
supposed to be really good for your yeah
what are those sneakers with their feet
sock things they're creepy you live
there
I was gonna say a primate we're all
[ __ ] friends you look like a [ __ ]
ape yeah all you need is your big toe to
be bet and some of you with hammer toes
gets one of those on a reverse hammer
toes with a [ __ ] the big toe sticking
out they're gonna look like a goddamn
chimp anyways let me plow ahead with the
podcast because your eggs are done I
just heard them alright alright alright
I'll see you I'll see you on the other
side of the cabin see that people that's
how you handle them right there right as
they're walking away you talk [ __ ] about
so getting back to that guy
my strategy yet is you don't you don't
lose your cool
you stay on target right like that dude
in Star Wars you stay on target and when
they're saying over-the-top mean [ __ ]
you don't respond to it because that's
just them you ever see a goat get choked
to death by a Python anybody else watch
those [ __ ] up YouTube videos you know
they're stunned at first they fight and
then there's that middle part like dude
what the [ __ ] what is this and then the
very end when they only have a little
bit of air left they [ __ ] kicking
their legs like a maniac before they die
that's the female version that's the
goat version getting killed by a Python
Jesus Christ of women when they start
saying that mean [ __ ] that's their last
little kick of the legs before it's over
so I don't respond to that [ __ ] anymore
actually I do a little bit but I've got
myself to the point where I know that
it's happening and then that's what I
did yesterday she started doing that
[ __ ] and I just took my plate of food
and I walked in the other room and I'm
telling you but the big thing is is if
you're wrong you have to admit it
because that gives you credibility in
the future so there you go sir and that
was an absolutely [ __ ] hilarious
email and it made it even funnier with
Mia sitting here taking it seriously
that's ridiculous he would he wouldn't
do that
I I'm calling [ __ ] he didn't jerk
off till he came like his wife I gotta
tell you though
that would be that would be [ __ ]
hilarious to do that I mean I could
stand there and rub my dick but it would
just be so funny to me I don't think I
could get a hard-on I got to be honest
with you oh that's disgusting
all right evidently I've been going off
on the French lately so some
american-born person who went over to
France which I don't know if I'm buying
I think they just want to hear my
opinions on what French people are
really like you know and I'm from
America so you can trust me like that
[ __ ] I always talk about on the whenever
there's some sort of political debate
the Obama is a [ __ ] and I'm a Democrat
all right here we go
hello mr. burr I enjoy your podcast very
much and I'm also a fan of your stand-up
um I don't mind you poking fun at the
French people too much I don't give a
[ __ ] whether you mind or not you're
condescending [ __ ] um even though I am
French I just wanted to inform you about
the stereotypes that's funny how come
you don't inform me about other
stereotypes that I do on this podcast oh
because it came around to you now you
give a [ __ ] okay
mainly the stereotypes about the French
or [ __ ] who hate America okay okay
this person's gonna debunk all these
okay or give me more information all
right number one Europeans generally
hate Americans because and I was born
and raised here so I can say this ma'am
or mister whoever wrote this [ __ ] you
could say it anyways all right stop
trying to get some sort of credibility
by saying you're from here I don't give
a [ __ ] where you're from all I know is
you live in France so you got
information and just just give it to me
all right all right Europeans generally
hate Americans because Americans go to
different countries and behave rudely
they expect things to be like in the
u.s. such as portion size and the
ability for everyone to speak English
whenever I go to France and see American
tourists I get so embarrassed because
they are obnoxious and expect everyone
to suck their superior American [ __ ] all
right
let's stop right there first of all when
Europeans come to America you guys act
like [ __ ] - yeah and it just goes
and you don't tip you don't give a [ __ ]
about our customs with tipping you don't
[ __ ] tip and then all you do is you
come to America and you trash it and I
gotta be honest with you when I go to
other countries I'm not a rude prick and
I would never go to another country and
then tell people who live there why
their country sucks
that's what Europeans do okay and you
kind of beat me to the punch here where
you say because they expect everyone to
suck this superior American [ __ ] I was
gonna say while you sound a little
insecure and she says or he says
Europeans also have inferiority issues
another reason they don't like Americans
I don't know how many times I've been
told by Swedes the English Germans and
so on that America sucks and is making
the world a worse place this makes me
extremely patriotic and want to defend
the US but I digress
from the French dude I actually feel
leagues I got agree with you all now and
that makes me want to defend it and it's
really funny if the English or the
Germans ever talk about a country making
the world a worse place okay because you
guys pass the baton to us we're standing
on the shoulders of your work of evil
Swedes I don't know anything about you
you weren't in any of my American
history classes the only first suite I
saw was on the Muppet Show
remember that bourgie bourgie or GD Borg
here we have a mushy B um but I
addressed with French number two the
French are not [ __ ] Parisians are
[ __ ]
oh Jesus Christ dude I wasn't born
yesterday really you have all your
[ __ ] quarantined just in Paris
there's not one [ __ ] up near the
beaches of Normandy huh or down in Nice
you telling me I go to cons film
festival there's not going to be some
local [ __ ] there is gonna be a [ __ ]
the French Riviera come on
okay evidently Nia all the [ __ ]
French people are just in Paris
so many Americans go to France and only
stay in Paris and then assume that all
of France is like Paris this is so
ignorant it infuriates me well you know
it's the [ __ ] jewel of your country
those are the smartest people you got
and when they're rude [ __ ] they are
your ambassadors who goes to [ __ ]
Paris to go to see a farm
I mean coast of France to go see a
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere let
me ask you this sir or ma'am if you
weren't lived in France and you came to
America where would you go would you go
to Nebraska God knows you wouldn't find
any intelligence out there
[ __ ] you buddy you try growing some corn
that is like going to New York City and
assuming that all Americans are like New
Yorkers Paris is like New York full of
unfriendly people who want you to get
out of their way big cities are like
that small towns are populated by nicer
people a trait common in all countries
well I'll definitely say they're much
polite or I will agree with that in
smaller towns but they also tend to be a
little more fearful and a lot more
racist and a lot more easier to sway
into putting saran wrap around their
outhouse because they believe that
they're gonna be the next victims of a
terrorist attack like logically that
works in their mind that the terrorist
attacks gonna be World Trade Center one
to the Pentagon and then you're out
house in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
like that's the next logical military
strategic target Jesus Christ is this
podcast even funny anymore sometimes
sometimes I just lose myself in the
sentences number three French women
shave the only women in France who don't
shave are the elderly Middle Eastern
immigrants last time I went to France I
told my aunts that Americans don't think
they shave and they were very upset by
this when I went to camp all the girls
shaved at the beach I went to the beach
they were all shaved in fact the French
say Scandinavians don't shave see
stereotypes about people in different
lands exist everywhere Wow
I think I learned something why the need
to
but down the women of foreign countries
because it's funny cuz that's what guys
do we break balls and we say your women
are ugly they're hairy their vaginas are
horizontal and they're not good lace and
we got bigger dicks and we can [ __ ] them
better it's basic [ __ ] talk page one
chapter one I've talking [ __ ] about
another country and I don't know I find
all of this to be very condescending you
know as you're sitting there saying
stereotypes exist everywhere and I love
how the French are getting offended by
what we think of them while they think
we're all illiterate fat [ __ ] go into a
to a Carl's jr. I mean it goes both ways
and I'll tell you why we think that
French women don't shave is because
there was a pop song over here a long
time ago a long time ago called 99 red
balloons no I dunno red balloons bla bla
bla bla bla bla pepper Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam yeah that [ __ ] right and
in the end of the video she puts her
arms up and had a hairy [ __ ] armpit
and that was it and she was from Germany
but it didn't matter to us all no
European women shaved that was it it was
over and plus when you look at your
continent and realize that it's
basically for the most part the meat of
it all right the countries that we give
a [ __ ] about is actually smaller than
our entire country like your countries
are the size of states over there so we
figure if they're not shaving in Germany
why wouldn't why would they shave and
[ __ ] France I mean if people in
Massachusetts are drunk morons do you
think that in Rhode Island they're
reading I don't know does that make any
sense I just feel like I'm coming off
dumber and dumber with each [ __ ]
podcast and uh you know what there's
something freeing about it
number four older Frenchman smell not
all the French back in the day and I
mean way back people didn't wear
deodorant my grandmother does and all
the other women you know what I'm
realizing I think a lot of the French
stereotypes came came around World War
in World War two you guys haven't needed
us to come over there and fight a
[ __ ] battle I'm joking I understand
that World War two was our payback for
you guys helping us out the
Revolutionary where I understand that
right
most of the Revolutionary War the French
and Indian War I can't [ __ ] remember
I have no idea I don't even remember
anymore they just all I hated that party
history any sort of powdered wigs
anything pre cowboys and Indians I just
could give a [ __ ] about and even then
that was very sketchy I liked reading
about the younger brothers Jesse and
Frank James Cole Younger I like reading
about that [ __ ] and I liked reading
about adventures at sea you know pirate
ships and that type of stuff you know
but anything with powdered wigs others
American presidents with the big bushy
beards and no mustaches it absolutely
put me to sleep so I can't remember so
there's a stereotype for you not only do
we not know about other countries we
don't even know about our own number
five French girls are [ __ ] well I'll
give you that one but the French on a
whole aren't as puritanical as Americans
yeah we're just all into getting STDs
and see sex as a private means of
pleasure that one shouldn't be too
ashamed of
I think it's healthier than keep your
legs closed because sex is evil you
[ __ ] view I definitely think yeah we
take it too far in this country but uh
last I saw the first AIDS patient caught
it in France out of my ass no pun
intended right knee is looking at me
that that's not true
the first guy who got it was was over in
France was a flight attendant patient
number one ground zero isn't that right
near no Jesus you know something some
day when I run for office I think that's
the one that's gonna come back to haunt
me anyways you know I was just [ __ ]
with you they a Frenchy
or former American person whatever um
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] one of my
dreams is to go to Paris and I think
that's gonna be happening later on this
year
why you ask well I'll tell you why if
you go to billboard.com
you'll notice that all of a sudden
mr. fancy-pants here has a a run of
dates throughout Scandinavia and in
October go to bill burr combi URR
go to the left hand in the left hand
corner you'll see all my dates and
scroll down to October I am doing
Helsinki Oslo Copenhagen and Stockholm
Sweden so I always get confused Oslo is
finland helsinki is norway stockholm
sweden I've been that Copenhagen Denmark
how [ __ ] awesome is that so I'm
tossing a one night in London before
that and at the end of that I think I'm
gonna go to Paris why the [ __ ] not right
that is if the American dollar doesn't
collapse in August and we're all in
worker camps speaking of that [ __ ] have
you guys seen this stuff about the all
the suicides at the the Apple plant you
know that really kunti commercial where
they go you know if you don't have an
iPhone then you don't have the iPhone
you know and I wanted to get an iPhone
until I saw those goddamn commercials
and they kept like just it's the most
bizarre advertising it makes me angry at
the iPhone I never had any anger towards
the iPhone other people who had one I
never gave a [ __ ] I was like iPhones to
[ __ ] I heard it drops calls I'll wait
till it's on Verizon and then right when
it gets on Verizon and I'm all ready to
jump on board they come up with this
nananananana [ __ ] kunti [ __ ] going
you know if you had an iPhone right now
you could be looking at the inside he a
[ __ ] throat and diagnosing your
[ __ ] throat cancer before it even
happens you know but if you don't have
the iPhone you know I'm the iPhone it's
like well [ __ ] you I'm cute sticking
with the Droid so anyways now I read
they just had the tenth suicide at the
Apple plant now who's kidding he'll we
all know that everything that we're
wearing everything that we're using is
made by some four-year-old making six
cents an hour somewhere
well evidently these people have had
enough they've had 10 suicides at the
Apple plant here we go in the same day
that Apple Dell hewlett-packard promised
to look into working conditions at
China's Foxconn plant 1/10 worker
committed suicide the death of a 19 year
old male worker that's too bad he was
like one year away from getting his
[ __ ] severance pay or his uh [ __ ] I
[ __ ] it up what the hell do you get it
when you do 20 years on the force oh
good I'm sorry everybody I'm on my
[ __ ] vacation mode what the hell I
get my pension what is that when you
work 20 years on the force and he's only
19 you get it because he's been working
since he was 2 the death of a 19 year
old male worker also came just after the
company's billionaire founder took the
media on tour of the sprawling complex
in response to accusations from labor
groups that workers toiled in sweatshops
like conditions Oh hilarious so then the
billionaire shows up they clean the
place up stick in a water bubbler and go
see it's great and I know what a lot of
you [ __ ] heartless [ __ ] are gonna
say you're gonna say well sweatshop
labor is necessary do you want to pay
$8,000 for a laptop well here's my
rebuttal you know what if the contact
atop didn't have to make a billion
dollars a year you know kind of like
when they were talking to the oil
companies they go your projected to make
350 billion how about you just make 340
billion
do you have to make that much money
that's the thing the people at the top
are taking way too much [ __ ] money
there's no [ __ ] way that the only
reasonable way to make a laptop is to
give people such shitty wages that
suicide is a better [ __ ] option and
you do it at the [ __ ] plant to make
some sort of political statement
there's just no [ __ ] way how about
the people at the top you mean once you
got a hundred million dollars
do you ever need to get another paycheck
I don't understand that I don't
understand that and I'm not saying that
the people at the top shouldn't be
filthy stinking rich because they came
up with it but you shouldn't be paying
people
this shouldn't be sweatshops everybody
that's all I'm saying
and what sucks is that we actually came
up with unions in this country because
of sweatshop like conditions and but
what ended up happening was the people
in the union's took advantage of it and
with their strength they became a bunch
of slothy douchebags to the point that
there's a lot of people actually have
negative views about unions that's how
bad it is in this country and they're
actually excited that they're gonna do
away with unions a lot of people want to
do away with [ __ ] unions rather than
reform them but to do away with them is
we're gonna end up like these poor
bastards and then [ __ ] China you know
so and [ __ ] together and going you know
what I think I'd rather jump out a
[ __ ] window then make another goddamn
iPhone um so anyways it says the company
has bought psychiatrists and Buddhist
monks to the factory to the factory
complex to support workers and now plans
now plays soothing music along
production lines why don't you just
[ __ ] pay them it plans to install
10-foot tall fences to stop workers
jumping from buildings and may give
workers a 20% pay raise this is how
tight these [ __ ] rich [ __ ] are let's
play soothing music and put a fence up
we'll try we'll try that first rather
than just giving them more money what is
it what is it
20 percent pay raise when you make it
eight cents an hour in anyways Foxconn
representatives maintain that the the
increase would not be in response to the
suicides but is being considered because
business has been good give me a [ __ ]
break do you hear that near the 10th
suicide at one of those Apple plants the
sweatshops they're killing themselves
over there so they decided to put up a
ten-foot wall so they can't jump and
they're playing soothing music and
they're considering giving them a 20%
pay raise
there you go yeah exactly
alright let's let's move on here a lot
of interesting great emails by the way
this week people sent me some really
interesting stuff here and [ __ ] that I
can actually help people out on here if
I could just get to the goddamn thing
people put your feet up here's a little
[ __ ] commercial here god damn you you
[ __ ] [ __ ] where the hell is it hi
you know some days I just really [ __ ]
hate myself and this is one of these
[ __ ] moments this guy sent me this
great email asking if maybe it was under
advice here it is here it is this was a
professional podcast I would have
[ __ ] edited this part out
all right advice bill this is gonna
sound a little gay but I'm gay so [ __ ]
you one of the great sentences ever
written on this podcast alright I'm a 22
28 year old guy whose hair is thinning
oh Jesus I always told myself that I
wouldn't be one of those guys who was
obsessed over this and I just shave it
off when it comes to it but in recent
years I've gotten lots of compliments on
my hair and I don't really ever hear any
compliments about anything else
regarding my appearance or my amazing
personality I kind of hate to be just
another dude with a shaved head walking
around getting fatter I'm considering
taking medication for hair growth but
the side effects include everything from
impotence to making the early stages of
prostate cancer to masking the early
stages of prostate cancer should it
develop what would you do do you risk
impotence and potential cancer in order
to keep the only thing about yourself
that receives compliments from others
I've noticed you've shaved your head in
the past but well I don't want to look
like that now I'm just [ __ ] with you
hey maybe I should just work out and get
ripped then it wouldn't matter right
well the thing about
going to the gym is [ __ ] that thoughts
all right well coming from another
balding [ __ ] male I said the exact
same things you said I swear mice you
know when I used to watch those
commercials and then watching these
people dump and [ __ ] on their head
they'd be like dude you shave your
[ __ ] head people make funny if for a
week and then they're used to it and
then they'd eventually see pictures with
you with hair and they go dude you look
weird with hair I like you better
without it
and then I started losing my hair and I
freaked the [ __ ] out I couldn't [ __ ]
believe it
you know I was like I was like that guy
in the 48 hours gans
when he finally gets shot I got shot I
can't believe I got hit remember that I
was that guy so I went out and I got the
Rogaine in that [ __ ] I dumped that [ __ ]
on my head and I felt my heart rate
increase it has different effects on
other people I know another guy took it
he said dude I was taking a piss and
chunks of something good what's in my
urine so umm I don't know I couldn't do
it I did I think I did it for a couple
of months and one point I just saw
myself in the mirror dumping that [ __ ]
on my head I was like what the [ __ ] am i
doing [ __ ] this you know I can't do this
[ __ ] so I said [ __ ] it and I stopped
using it and and then I just shaved my
head and I said [ __ ] it and and I gotta
admit I haven't a shaved head is [ __ ]
awesome but what ended up happening was
I booked that movie date night they go
we want you to grow your hair out a
little bit so I grew it out and then I
started booked another [ __ ] by the way
what I booked I've been joking around I
gotta set the record straight here
because people are really starting to
believe that I'm on Glee yeah I gotta
tell him because then like people are
like twittering then I'm on Glee and
they're gonna miss the show I'm actually
I'm not on Glee I actually I booked two
episodes of my favorite show on [ __ ]
TV Breaking Bad and the only reason why
I said that was because they're super
top secret about their scripts they
don't want anybody to know anything and
I wasn't even sure if it was okay to say
you even
booked a roll on it I didn't know I
didn't know if they were that top-secret
about it so I just started joking around
saying I was on Glee and then I did the
show a couple of times to that some
they're like no no it's fine but I was
so far down the road with that lie so I
just kept saying so I am NOT on Glee and
shame on you people actually believed
that I was flying to New Mexico to do an
episode of Glee and that we were doing
the pee-wee Herman Mexican Hat dance
really really you really fell for that
one but anyways yes so so I grew my hair
back out and and but I'm still not using
anything and I'm starting to get the
Friar Tuck thing in the back of my head
and but you know once you shave your
head you don't give a [ __ ] about going
bald you just kind of keep it short and
I if I was you [ __ ] gay dude you got
to do it shave your head because you're
trying to attract other guys and guys
were superficial [ __ ] and we we're a
hundred percent about looks I think if
you shave your head
that says a lot about you you got
confidence you're not trying to hide
anything and you deal with you deal with
with the [ __ ] in your life you don't try
to hide it and stick some magic goop on
top of your head not to mention I think
they're gonna cure it one day you know
when when we I'm in my 80s and you're in
like your 70s or some [ __ ] they're gonna
cure it we'll just pop a pill you know
have a full head of jet-black [ __ ]
hair you know and we won't have the
[ __ ] ass cancer right so that's what
I would say shave your head right and go
to the gym and get shredded all right as
far as your attitude towards the gym if
you don't want to go to the gym and
you're just gonna become a fat [ __ ] it's
not gonna matter I don't even think
you're gonna live long enough to even go
bald alright so go to the shave your
head go to the [ __ ] gym I'm telling
you having a shaved head is the [ __ ] and
I really want to [ __ ] do it again and
I will in the future at some point I'm
just gonna be when I have two nature's
gradually doing it for me
so dude you should try if you never had
a shaved head it's [ __ ] awesome
it's awesome you just wake up you're
ready to go you're [ __ ] ready to go
and who gives a [ __ ] right think about
it don't you think if you were gonna be
Brad Pitt it would have happened by now
what are you really worried about are
you worried that your ranking on the
world People magazine's 50 most
beautiful people is now in jeopardy
that you're not gonna make it have you
ever made it before you know actually
shouldn't make these jokes with you cuz
you kind of seem like you have low
self-esteem
alright you know what your problem is
dude I think that you're a little shy
and you're sitting around eating
cupcakes and feathering your [ __ ]
hair alright you need to start eating
more protein and some vegetables go to
the [ __ ] gym and shave your head BAM
gavel hits a [ __ ] next case
next case that's it it's over alright
moving on I asked people last week about
coaching talking about crazy stories
with coaches and that type of thing and
I had a crazy coach and I can't even
[ __ ] tell you this [ __ ] this guy did
just because people I know from my
childhood listen to this thing so I
really have to [ __ ] watch it
sometimes so um alright here's his one I
don't know I don't know what I did with
the email I'm gonna paraphrase I just
remembered this guy said he he was
playing on a baseball team he was like
in the fifth grade I think and he was
the kid who played right field he wasn't
good or whatever so they're they're
playing the game that's before the game
that's before the game for the
championship so I guess they're in the
[ __ ] semies and there's a guy on
second and that down by a run and
they're getting down to the final inning
and he's coming up to bat and he sucks
so he's already nervous and he said his
coach went up grabbed him by the arm and
looked him in the face and said hey if
you don't get a hit I'm gonna punch you
right in the face and he said it first
he laughed because he thought the coach
was joking trying to break the tension
and then he realized that the dude was
serious and he just sort of walked up to
the plate and he was standing up there
[ __ ] his pants
and he looked back this coach and his
coaches staring right at him like I'm
gonna punch you in the [ __ ] face if
you don't get a [ __ ] hit so this kid
throws the bat out there and he somehow
slaps a [ __ ] Derek Jeter's opposite
field single drives in the run said at
the end of the inning he went back to
the bench he said the coach never said
anything to him never addressed it again
and he says he's hated that son of a
[ __ ] from to this day so he said his
question was what is this guy is he is
he a good motivator is he a horrific
human being I mean this is the thing
it's because you got a hit I think
that's a weird one that that one is that
guy is both right and wrong he's wrong
for taking the game so seriously and
injecting that sort of reality into your
childhood which I think kids should get
a dose of reality in their childhood but
I think it should come from the parents
or at least the parents should be
supporting another adult like say you
[ __ ] up in school when your parents go
there old school parents would go to
school and whatever the teacher said you
were doing the the parent would then
look at look at the kid and be like yeah
why the [ __ ] are you doing that but
something like this I don't know he did
motivate you he did let you know what
the real world is like he basically gave
you in a nutshell yeah in life you know
when when when society needs you to
produce if you don't produce it kicks
you in the balls and you you don't get
the position you don't get you don't get
a [ __ ] raise or whatever the [ __ ] it
is I'm trying to say I got damn and I
can't talk this [ __ ] week you know
what I'm saying here's another story
from coaching bill loved the podcast but
but uh I am Cote I'm a coach I coach a
team ages nine to ten I'm the assistant
for a a you travel team is that ninth to
tenth grade they're traveling there's
got to be that the travel teams coach
and my son are on my nine ten team
that's got to be nine to ten years old
and they travel
are they Vietnamese I don't know they
let American kids do that both are very
good players and are two of the four
best players on my team I have three
slots for the all-star team oh Jesus Oh
God so you're the coach you got two kids
on your team and they're two out of the
four best players on my team I have
three slots for the all-star team all
right so two slots are taken and now
it's down to my son and the travels
coach's son well why don't you give away
those first two slots with I guess if
those kids were better than then your
son and your buddies kid okay so his son
is hitting 600 placed third third base
shortstop in second and has pitched 5
good innings in 6 games he has only
fielded about 6 balls but that's not his
fault
my son is hitting 6 12 hey you know what
the podcast listeners I want you guys to
vote for this like this is the MLB all
right so the first guys kids hitting 600
he's played third short and second he's
pitched 5 good innings in 6 games and
he's fielded only about 6 balls but
that's not his fault because he can't
control who hits it to him his son is
hitting 6 12 has caught every has caught
every inning except the 3 innings he
pitched he's thrown out eight people in
6 games and in 4 of the 5 games we won
the other team's catchers sucked and we
just stole our way around the bases
even without past balls we have not we
have not had a player thrown out
stealing well this has to do with the
rest of your team
the game we lost their pitchers shut us
down in short in the six games he is
hands-down the best pitch catcher I've
seen the travel coaches son has a little
higher level fielding but I feel my son
had a bigger impact on our team batting
is a push oh because he's 662 who do I
pick for the all-star team
[ __ ] alright dude if you weren't related
to your kid you got you got a uh you got
to pick your kid he's um he's batting
twelve points higher and he's gunning
down the other teams runners you know so
after the pitcher [ __ ] up he's
correcting the pitchers [ __ ] while not
[ __ ] up himself and hitting 612 but
it's your son ah Jesus well I mean you
can give it to your son I think he's
worthy of it but you know you know
jeopardize your friendship with the
other person if you're fine with that I
give it to your kid but you know if you
want to teach your kid a little bit of
something about being humble and about
handling a position of power properly
I'd give it to the friend I think that
that's what I do but I would sit down
and I would I would have a talk with
your son and try to explain that the
position of power that you're in and how
it would look Jesus Christ this sounds
like a McDonald's commercial doesn't it
back in the day when they'd sing some
sad song and the kid wouldn't get it at
first then you buy him some french fries
and a [ __ ] vanilla shake you know
it's times like these I'm glad I'm not a
parent dude wow that's it that's a
that's a tough one
that is a tough one all right well I got
time for one last one here hey Bill I'm
a 27 year old graphic web designer and
I've been unemployed for a few months
now the job I had a few months back was
a web development job at a company I
thought was awesome before I worked
there but turned out to be real a really
shady place that had a really bad
history of having high turnover with
their employees in any case I've been
living back with my parents now for two
years because I lost a job back then and
had just enough money saved up to live
out the 13 month lease that I had signed
on my previous apartment ever since I've
been struggling to find work like I'm
sure a lot of people are however almost
all my friends have jobs are been able
to find jobs fairly easy easily when
they didn't have one I attribute this
mainly to the fact that they are most
that they mostly have jobs not careers
like I've been trying to build over the
line
half a decade or so but with it being so
hard to find a job I'm wondering if I
should take up a new career
I love graphic and web design and I'm
damn good at it too
I've even been looking for jobs out in
California area because Florida sucks
and I'm not a fan of a hundred degree
weather with tons of humidity but it's
it's been more difficult to find work
out there because most places won't even
consider me since I'm not living out
there yet I have no money to just up and
move without any concrete and employment
on the line what should I do
alright yeah dude you're getting your
stories right now every successful man
has his stories about sleeping on a
futon eatin [ __ ] Eggo waffles those
are the years you're in so what I would
do is I would get a job get a [ __ ]
job anything you got to do get a [ __ ]
job get some money coming in and then
save up your money okay during the day
that's your day job just like I had I
had a day job working in a warehouse and
at nights I did comedy for free at night
you come home you do your graphic
designing for free okay get a job will
you meet other people maybe the company
needs some sort of graphic designing you
can offer up your services you know and
then you can add that to your resume and
then there's other people maybe have
side businesses I'd get a business card
I put that up all around town cheap
graphic designing just happy to be here
graphic and web designing that's what I
would do I get that business going and
while I kept working my day job and
eventually you will have enough [ __ ]
money your graphic design will be making
enough [ __ ] money well you can either
move out to California or [ __ ]
California run your own goddamn business
all right
I'd say what your problem is is you're
being too damn picky all right you got
to do whatever you got to do fake it
till you make it right now and I'm
basing that on the fact that you've
stuck with looking for a career rather
than a job that's a good thing sometimes
I can shoot you in the foot and also how
you want to leave Florida because you
don't like the weather all right right
now is not the time to be a diva deal
with the [ __ ] humidity bust your
[ __ ] ass all right don't get into a
relationship with some woman you don't
need it right now what you need to do is
to rub one out in the morning go to that
[ __ ] job no and as you're at the job
try to network with people if you
[ __ ] you I'm just gonna say
everything that I just said just do all
that [ __ ] bust your [ __ ] ass and
you'll get there and you have all these
great stories all right then you get a
good-looking broad at the end of it
because God knows they like money all
right that's the that's the podcast for
this week everybody I hope you enjoyed
it I got another couple days up here I'm
gonna enjoy my [ __ ] vacation gonna go
jet ski and I'm gonna have some stories
about that and I'm gonna bring my bear
mace on another hike today I hope you
guys all have a good week
and let's go Bruins I'm looking for them
to turn it around no disrespect to the
Vancouver Canucks they got a beast of a
[ __ ] team I just don't think there's
anybody tough on your team which is
evident when you're going around biting
people's fingers like [ __ ] a goddamn
toddler who just got his [ __ ] toy
taken away from him all right that's the
podcast for this week I'll talk to you
later go [ __ ] yourselves
[Music]